the Tennessee Cop fired over the
numerous romps you know a little bedroom
activity with other officers claims that
a new federal lawsuit that her superiors
in her Department groomed her have you
remembered we covered this video a
couple weeks back okay and we talked
about her and we said a bunch of
different things basically she was out
here banging everyone while she was
married in an open relationship but her
husband didn't want her to be begging
other dudes on the job she did it
anyways yeah when he found out that his
other patrolmen were patrolling her
inside I get it I'm not mad at it I
understand why you'd be upset everybody
got fired yeah especially those who lied
about it because most of them did and
honestly like if you guys read the
detail like they were they was filthy
wow they was doing stuff on the job in
the police cars in the change rooms they
was
how old is she 26. it's not grooming
this video is done uh yo tell us what
you think like subscribe I get what
you're saying
it's not grooming I disagree to a degree
kind of not really me I don't know
[__] [__]
I said this last video I said in this
situation I place more accountability on
the superiors than her reason being is
their positions of leadership yeah one
it looks terrible for your organization
when the boss is out here [__] their
employees it just looks terrible it
doesn't matter what the reality the
situation is doesn't matter how fine we
can make it looks terrible it looks bad
for the people working with you it looks
bad for the people who want to apply it
looks bad for like creating an
environment that you're supposed to be
safe and professional it looks terrible
and if you're in a position of
leadership you have more powers that
means you have more privileges that
means you have more responsibilities
okay I place more blame on the dudes for
that reason alone not because they're
mad not because they're women if you're
the one who's the boss and you [__]
you're gonna hold the L it looks really
bad when multiple superiors ran through
the same young up and coming cop what's
the second reason because there's some
[__] like thick comes out right if some
[__] like this comes out what you gonna
do oh I didn't groom her well you were
her bias how do we know you didn't give
her any orders how that's not grooming
that's abusing power
definition of grooming is uh grooming is
when someone builds a relationship trust
and emotional connection with a child or
person or a young person so they can
manipulate exploit and abuse them it's
not the definition I read up on what is
grooming in adults so
was she I don't think so based off the
message says she seemed like a very
willing participant in fact she seemed
like she was the one pressing the issue
sometimes but again it doesn't really
matter because you cannot be in a
workplace and [__] your subordinates
they ran a train on a subordinate
they all passed her around
like hot potatoes Hot Potato Hot Potato
Hot Potato Hot Potato Hot Potato and
there's nothing hot about her but it's
still a potato flying around you get me
no it's true it is what it is you look
at her and honestly if she was in sorry
yeah I was about to say she was an
animorph you know animals oh [__] you're
beautiful
you know where the anamorph is just
transforming but like they stop in the
middle and you see like the frame but it
doesn't matter it's a side it's a side
teeth it doesn't matter this just shows
you it just shows you men will [__]
everything she got she got some cheeks
and she got she got we going in you
thought these [__] was moles the way
they going into holes it's correct they
see a woman say that again
say that [__] run that [__] back ready
I had to rewind that
man don't [__] anything but
what they look like you thought they was
moles the way they was Japanese
FX
yo I'm gonna lie all these guys got a
whole big else oh my they deserve to be
fired imagine losing your career and
jeopardizing your family your marriages
everything days four that yo I mean if
you would have lost it for Beyonce I'd
be like hey man careers come and go you
you split that [__] but single ladies
are forever right you know that that's
something I would have got well firing
this one yeah I would have been like
Jay-Z sloppy seconds yeah I would have
been proud this one is yours this one is
this this one is you what oh you slept
good [__] Hey listen you fix your neck
cause you say my neck hurt and [__] last
time we feel oh you sort that [__] out
my Man Came Out Swinging there you go
moles and holes
I think that she Moses
hey most of the holes I think that's
gonna be the title of this video
that's what some of you guys are oh
you're dead ass she could be Mount
cameras and you guys would still jump in
it's crazy
I can't even be that mad cause at 21 I
was like that too but as a man in his
mid-30s with a full-on career I thought
with everything for that
you slept good you ain't good you good
hey you are swinging my man God damn
shout out sir but ladies just goes to
show you when you guys make the first
when you guys make the first move you'd
be surprised by your success rate mental
ruin their lives for you yeah just cause
you said hi go out there metal be like
wife kids [__] them
was that Frozen song [__] it all [__]
yeah [__] it up I'ma stick my dick in
the house you understand women how much
power you have over men men will destroy
everything
for a hole
and a whole lot so there you guys have
it let us know what you guys think in
the comments what you want to reaction
let me just see if there's more
information about this because we just
read off the headline that we started
God damn bro you went out there
Where Mrs Hall sought Role Models at her
new job she instead of found predators
in place of offering professional
development herself fears and the chief
of police groomed her first for
exploitation they colluded in using
their authority to systematically disarm
her resistance and trap her into
degrading and sexual relationships even
sharing tips on the best ways to
manipulate and exploit her
I don't know what they're talking about
there but if this issue is true then it
sounds like it you imagine these guys
like oh yo
go tell her her [__] tastes good she'll
[__] you
the suit claims Hall who had a history
of mental illness felt trapped in an
attempt to escape she nearly offed
herself
how the [__] were you a cop with a
history of mental illness
I got to ask that first question
my dude I know some cops with a history
of mental illness facts God damn look at
this guy he's one of the first ones to
get it in
K9 what up dog
she's stupid
I have to swing one
no you know like he looks like a darker
version of Nate Dogg yeah yeah he does
okay so this is how the alleged he
groomed her Sergeant Powell learned that
Miss Hall was going through the process
of buying a home with her husband and
that the process was extremely taxing on
the relationship Powell positioned
himself as a reliable source of
companionship advice regarding Miss
Hall's career and her marriage Powell
persisted in requests for uh bedroom
activities despite Mrs Hall's resistance
eventually Miss Hall gave into Powell's
request for favors earlier this month
Laverne's police chief Burrell chip
Davis has also fired Hall claims the
chief encouraged this behavior and
shared in the photos and fantasies of
mutually
going after Mrs Hall with his trusted
supervisor time going
she said Davis once asked her to come
into his office to dance for him and try
to get her to agree to lunch dates and
described her clothing as hot girl
summer
what the [__]
what the [__] did you what the what the
[__] did you say let me just make sure I
read that the police chief said yo your
clothing is some hot girls summer [__]
what are you talking about hey this [__]
caught a wild man yeah this don't fire
me what the [__] this apartment more
turned up than a strip club turn it up
what the [__] is going on no this is a
wild Department [__] hey man listen
that's some of the details you guys can
read up on if you want to but that
that's what they that's what they got
caught you guys gotta hold that down
that [__] crazy what is the other [__]
that [__] was crazy
hot girl summer [__] yo come my office
do a little dance hot girl summer [__]
that is mad I'm not gonna lie anything
else you want allegedly I'm not gonna
lie that's some of that [__] sounded
real yeah what's up with that [__]
Sounder and the fact that they fired the
police chief yeah they don't fire him
for no reason apparently he didn't smash
but apparently he was involved in
different ways and they found evidence
of that so what I know is this she's
claiming this stuff but they've already
found these guys doing bad things so
what she's claiming I doubt is a lot I
bet you there's evidence of what she
claims it seemed like but anyways maybe
y'all disagree maybe I feel differently
my expectation they're gonna settle this
out of court because they want to move
past this they do not expect her they do
not want all that [__] to be aired out
I'll say she might be a whole but she a
whole lot of smart so she about to get
paid you dig she about to make millions
off of this for being a thought don't
get that but how about you don't I don't
listen the text message I saw from her
to them she sounded like she was really
excited and knowing they were in an open
relationship and she was willingly doing
some of this stuff I don't I don't buy
that this was all like [__] it was not
all one-sided but if I'm gonna be
embarrassed by the department I would
probably also Sue to get some money so
you know I understand why she's doing it
she probably can't go out in public
without people being like yeah okay hot
girl summer you still protected and
serving cause you should be protected
because I could use some surfaces okay
so I just this is what I'm saying so I
understand but anyways this is all my
thoughts anything else let us know
[Music]